this is actually really shrewd technique
from wesley he is maximizing his chances
and now
where is alireza going to move his rook
he's losing his feelings
i'm surprised by this he's losing his
pawn now for russia he's shaking his
head he's given a check
maybe he was trying to work out
something else but his pawn has dropped
and suddenly wesley has real winning
chances oh wow the black king is cut off
so it's not easy but
he's two pawns down and two pawns down
in a rook end game means it's going to
be difficult and for russia i think he
thinks he's losing but i mean how is
black going to make progress
the black king is cut off the black king
cannot pass the g-file right now
he just has to wait with his rook oh for
rusia he thinks he's lost
he's going to try and bring the king
round to attack black's pawn but that
looks slow
okay black's king is coming the white
king as soon as it marches forward the
black rook can actually come to the e4
square the black rook's going to come
across now and cut off that king from
marching to the right
wesley might now win the game wow
okay pressure is on all the rest of
russia he keeps making moves with one
second left on the clock
okay yeah wesley his task his king is
cut off but the black king is just going
to come march down on the h line there
we go it's going to come as near as
possible to the white rook and then at
the right moment black will give up one
of his pawns and start matching the
other pawn further
i mean
can you not also move his rook
to two squares to the right do it now
and then okay and this pawn is marching
he's lost track of this one pawn he's
not going to save the game anymore ah so
close and yet so far away i know
he fought back from a difficult position
it was just one or two accurate moves
within his grasp it was the clock in the
end didn't have enough time to work it
out and now the rook comes back trying
to stop black's pawns advancing
but black can do anything pretty much he
can move the black rook free up his f
pawn to start marching forward as well
both okay he matches this one
the black brook will defend that pawn
there we go and now
two pawns are both running white's rook
is passive white's king is too far away
this is game over and he resigns wow
this is getting dramatic you guys wesley
so a huge comeback two wins in a row to
take it
to
tie breaks woo that's coming